you'll really be having her do whatever
the hell she wants
my baby cardi b just shared that clip of
offset
giving their two-year-old daughter a
manicure and let me just tell you
it doesn't get cuter than this is she so
cute i love her
on tuesday the up rapper posted the
sweet daddy daughter moment with offset
and culture on her instagram
story calling out the pair's shenanigans
you'll really be having her do whatever
the hell she wants my baby
i don't know what i love most the bright
pink nail polish
the concentration on the migos rapper's
face
the moment he says she's his baby
like i said cuteness overload
you'll really be having her do whatever
the hell she wants it's my baby
pretty stay pretty
wow we stan a girl dad and we blessed
man
and cardi well she's the ultimate girl
mom
oh yes honey the 28 year old recently
let culture give her a makeover
and she shared this video of her little
girl using her face
as a canvas i look pretty
hmm
it seems like little culture has
inherited her mama's passion for glitz
and glam
back in july for her second birthday
culture received her first hermes birken
bag from her famous parents
wow
[Music]
and while cardi and her sweet fam are
living the glam life
she recently revealed she wants them to
move to a ranch
i really want to have a farm and i'm
trying to convince my
husband that we can actually have a farm
in our property
but i've never been around farm animals
the grammy winner made that revelation
on her facebook series
cardi tries and while offset may not be
down for the ranch life
one thing's for sure cardi totally
looked the part
i just want to look cute while i'm
breeding these animals so whatever
well goodbye
you